Elliot in the final 24 hours before the
vote Netanyahu shocked many reversing
his earlier position and coming out
formally against Palestinian statehood
some here said it came across as
desperate is there a sense there that it
won him the election Olivia certainly
Netanyahu managed to shore up his
right-wing base in the last 24 hours of
this election that declaration saying
that on his watch there would be no
Palestinian state a statement of the
obvious some would say but certainly not
something that would have gone down well
with the Palestinians the White House or
Israel's European allies that certainly
was not the most shocking thing he said
the most shocking thing was a video he
posted on his Facebook page yesterday
urging people to come out and vote
because there was a large Arab turnout
at the opinion part at the at the polls
at the polls yesterday something that
hasn't traditionally happened when he
was worried that the arab parties the
United Arab list might steal some votes
away from him or he would have a tougher
time in Parliament but of course some
people might see his desperation others
in the future looking back may see this
simply as a series of tactical
masterstroke because ultimately it
worked he pinched some votes from
further to the right and is now the
biggest party in parliament likely to be
Prime Minister again Elliot do we have
any early sense of what his coalition is
going to look like in what that'll mean
for policy he says he's already spoken
with the leaders of the other right-wing
parties with a view to forming some kind
of coalition certainly it will remain as
it was regarding the regarding Iran as
for the Palestinians I think Netanyahu
was already pretty much said there's no
chance of peace talks there's no point
in peace talks resuming because there's
not going to be a Palestinian state on
his watch not that it would be able to
be wrapped up even with the best of will
in the world within a four-year prime
ministerial term but still the the mood
music is not right for that to resume
and he's also going to focal on
socio-economic matters as well